we begin this morning with signs of a
struggling economy and yet another test
for president biden the labor department
said friday that only 194 thousand jobs
were created in september that is far
less than what most analysts had
expected
unemployment ticked down to 4.8 percent
nationwide lower than expectations and
the lowest since february of last year
but it's due in part to 180 000 fewer
job seekers last month christina raffini
is at the white house this morning good
morning christina
good morning michelle as you mentioned
some of the dip in unemployment is
because people stopped looking for work
now president biden was quick to point
out those numbers are from last month
when coveted cases were higher and said
that if congress would pass those two
major pieces of legislation stalled out
on the hill it would help
jobs up wages up unemployment down
that's progress but less progress than
expected the economy added 300 000 fewer
jobs last month than anticipated
president biden tried to emphasize the
positive
for the first time since march of 2020
the american unemployment rate is below
five percent
a significant improvement
from when i took office and a sign that
our recovery is moving forward lingering
health and safety concerns are hindering
that recovery the latest figures show
there are 1.5 jobs available for every
unemployed american the largest gap in
u.s history people are still fearful of
covid
and what it will be like in workplaces
and ensuring their own safety the labor
shortage is being felt by businesses
across the country in an effort to
recruit bank of america announced it was
boosting its minimum wage to 21 dollars
an hour and this california casino is
offering signing bonuses to try to fill
nearly 200 open jobs never in my career
have we seen such a demand in the
workforce
cook richie adlen's new gig came with a
2500 appetizer you get to love your jobs
you're going to love what you do i mean
i love doing that there is less love
however between house progressives and
certain senate democrats i would like
them to recognize that they're just two
senators and 96 percent of democrats in
the house and the senate and the
president agree with the american people
still trying to work out a path forward
for the bipartisan infrastructure bill
and the larger 3.5 trillion dollar
social spending plan legislation
president biden says will directly
impact the american economy these bills
are not about left versus right
or modern versus progressive these bills
are about competitiveness versus
complacency
now it's not all bad news senate
republicans and democrats did come
together and get a deal on raising the
nation's debt limit something economists
and markets were really worried about
compromising that sluggish recovery the
house will convene on tuesday to vote on
the measure jeff
okay christina thank you very much